Ever heard somebody say that Ukrainian is
just Russian with an accent?
Russia tried banning Ukrainian twice.
In 1863 a Russian minister declared
Ukrainian to be "not real", just a
twisted version of Russian.
Then in 1876 Tsar
Alexander II made it worse.
Ukrainian was banned in books, in
schools, in place, in education.
These weren't small rules, this was
full-on language erasure.
Schools were silenced, churches were
closed, printing was outlawed.
But Ukraine didn't give in.
Secret schools, exile presses and
families whispering Ukrainian
poems kept the language alive.
Today some call Ukraine "little Russian"
or "Novorossiya" "new Russia".
But when a culture not only survives two
bans and centuries of repression,
it is not just fake, it is resilient.